JENNY MURPHY: Hey everyone.
Welcome to another session
of the Google+
platform office hours.
So this week we're going to be
watching a really cool demo of
a really cool hack that was
written by some students at
University of Washington.
And we have one of them on now
and hopefully some more later
who will field some questions
and talk a little bit about
their hacking experience on
the hangout chat platform.
And then after that we're going
to field some questions
that you either asked ahead
of time, or you
can ask us live now.
There's actually a link
in the post on
Google+ developers page.
So I guess to get started let's
do some introductions.
So we're just going
to go around.
First, we're going to start with
everyone in the room here
at the Google Plex.
I'm Jenny Murphy, I'm a
developer programs engineer
here at Google.
And I work on the Google+
platform,
mostly on the rest APIs.
And I'm also kind of
MCing this video.
And next to me I have--
MALE SPEAKER 1: I'm [? Trai ?]
I'm also a developer of
programs engineer.
I also work on the Google+
platform, and I also work on
the Google API PHP
client library.
JOHN: I'm John Bavary, develop
advocate on Google+.
And I deal a lot with hangouts
and stuff like that.
JENNY MURPHY: And how about our
guests, starting with the
green background--
SUI: Hey, I'm Sui.
I'm an undergrad computer
science student from
University of Washington.
And I'm a senior this year.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
And last but not least--
Min?
MIN: Hello, I'm Min.
I'm a computer science
engineering major, and I'm a
this year too.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
So we're going to
switch over now.
Because they were writing
a hangouts app, we can't
actually show you a hangouts app
in an on-air hangout yet.
We were going to do the really
crude method of playing a
video that they recorded of
their really cool hack.
So we're going to switch over
now, so bear with us as we
switch the microphones around,
we'll be back in a sec.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1:
Hi everybody.
So we viewed this Google hangout
karaoke application,
which is called Google Idol.
Now we are going to give
our brief introduction
of how to use it.
SUI: So now we will be
showing our search
and add song feature.
So we're going to go to add
song, and then we're going to
look for Britney Spears.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1:
I can't scroll.
SUI: Baby one more time.
Click Search, and there will
be a bunch of videos.
I think maybe this one
might be nice.
And I have just clicked on this
music video and then it
will add it to the queue that
we have on the left.
On the right we see buttons for
different sound effects.
So here we have doh sound, doh,
laughing sound, [LAUGHTER]
Applauding,
[APPLAUSE]
And
boos, [BOOING]
And at any time during the song
session users can click
on the sounds to make
sound effects.
And we also have two
instrumental sounds that can
be also played at any time.
So a drum.
[DRUM BEATS]
And also piano.
[PIANO MUSIC]
And the users can use these
to enhance their karaoke
experience.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: And to play a
video, or karaoke video, we
can just click on the
video in this song
queue area to our left--
so, click.
And it appears in the
center screen.
SUI: For the demo, we decided
to sing jingle bells.
We had other songs in the
previous version of the demo,
but because of
copyright issues [BOOING]
We tried to look for songs that
were written way before
the copyright years.
And so here's jingle bells.
[JINGLE BELLS PLAYING]
[GIRLS SINGING JINGLE BELLS]
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Why am I the
only person singing here?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: One cool
feature of our app is the real
time voting.
So while someone is performing,
or at any time, we
can all cast votes.
So here I'll cast vote two.
And SUI, vote something.
And then Min--
Min?
OK.
And in real time our
vote changes.
So it reflects what we think
about the current song and
current performance.
SUI: So now you can see the
spotlight in front.
MIN: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SUI: So the speed of
light is actually
controlled by your volume.
So let's see--
so whenever like one of the
persons is making some noise
the dots are speed up.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Min,
say something.
SUI: I don't see the dots.
SUI: I see it.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I see it.
Keep talking.
Min, keep talking.
MIN: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
SUI: Just say something.
Say hi.
MIN: Hi.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: OK.
SUI: That's so cool.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: OK, so you've now
seen a hangout app running
in a video, in a web browser, in
a hangout, screen share, in
your web browser.
So if that wasn't enough
pillaring and letter-boxing, I
don't know what is.
In post production we're
going to clean that up.
So if you didn't get a great
view of that video it will be
spliced in once we upload
to YouTube.
So thanks for bearing with
us with that experiment.
But, the app was awesome.
MIN: Thank you.
JENNY MURPHY: Really cool.
Really cool work.
So if you don't mind, I'd like
to ask you guys a couple
questions, or five questions
about your development
experience.
Just chime in, either of
you or you both can
answer it if you like.
So, have either of you or did
anyone on your team have any
development experience writing
real time applications like
that before--
where there's collaboration
between a bunch of people?
SUI: I have done some real time
chatting application before.
But it wasn't like
real time gaming.
And I also had done a couple
of other hackathon events.
For [? arrow ?]
I built this little I enjoy a
game application for toddler.
And it was like a mask game,
using speech recognition
technology.
But I don't think I have done
any social gaming things.
That's my experience.
MIN: For me I really didn't
have any experience before
doing the hangout app.
I mainly just developing
web applications,
nothing real time.
Or not to be any real
time aspect to it.
So yeah, that was the
first time for me.
JOHN: I just want to know,
what was your first time
experience since you guys
never really had done
anything like that?
Has it been hard, was there
a learning curve?
SUI: Yeah, I think the hardest
part actually was the initial
set up stage and then the
final integration stage.
So we had to start one day
before to get familiar with
the API, and then try to set
up the simple application.
And to make sure all the
configuration are set up correctly.
And also, I think our goal with
hangout API was using
sort of live socket
technology.
So we have a lot
of [? states--
like state, exchange state,
those kind of things.
I haven't really done
those things before.
So you it take a while to get
familiar with a concept like
how to add space and remote
space, and then exchange
things, those kind of things.
JOHN: So when you say a while,
how long was the hackathon?
SUI: It was 24 hours.
JOHN: OK, OK.
Relatively short in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, so did you
guys actually do all that
development in 24 hours
during the hackathon?
Because that's a really
polished hack.
SUI: Yeah, well, I would
say it wasn't that
polished after 24 hours.
I had to spend a day
afterwards to
actually polish the UI.
But for limited to that
24 hours, I think
we did a good job.
And we actually used up
the entire 24 hours.
We didn't get any sleep
at all, that was hard.
But we were really determined
though.
We think we are going
to win something.
JENNY MURPHY: Wow, that's really
some dedication there.
That's very impressive.
So while you were developing it,
what did you find the most
challenging part of
your experience?
SUI: Min, you want to take it?
MIN: Well, I think because we
weren't familiar with the API
itself we had to read a
lot of documentation.
So before the competition we
were sort of experimenting
with the sample applications.
And so that helped a little bit,
but when we actually were
developing application we did
use some of their codes
tailored to our application.
But it's always very limited
in some aspects.
And so, I guess the learning
curve to learn the API and the
technologies, and the very fact
that we're just using
javascript to make an
application was a
challenge in itself.
Other than that--
I guess a trying challenge was
the fact that we couldn't do
the main feature that
we were thinking of.
So we were trying to cope with a
way to share the video after
the hangout.
So we're recording a video and
audio files and then sharing
it, that was our goal.
At that time I don't think the
Google API supported that, at
least not to my knowledge.
And so we had to work
around that and
come up with new features.
So I guess that was our biggest
challenge, other than
the developing aspect.
JENNY MURPHY: Well given the
challenges you faced you guys
did some amazing stuff.
So this kind of leads into
my next question--
what is on your dream list
for hangouts apps?
What feature would you really
like to see added to the
platform for this application,
or any other things you're
brainstorming?
SUI: OK, so as he mentioned
before, we were really
expecting doing the
recording part.
But I know a Google hangout
has recording feature, but
maybe not for API
to my knowledge.
JENNY MURPHY: You're right,
it's not available yet.
SUI: OK, so we were thinking it
would be cool to recap the
entire karaoke experience, and
people were having a lot of
fun afterward.
And another thing we
were thinking--
was there a way to manipulate
the speaker's voice so we can
add more DJ mixing effects
like autotune
those kind of things--
so make the experience fuller.
JENNY MURPHY: That would be
really cool, autotune and then
hangout karaoke.
That would help a lot
of us singers.
Very cool.
So, now that you've written that
neat application, what's
next for that app?
Are you going to continue
development on it?
SUI: Yeah--
I don't know but them.
I definitely want to keep
doing, working on this.
And if possible we can
collaborate with people from
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], or collaborate
with the API so it
can more exposed to a more
available technology we can
use and into our application.
JENNY MURPHY: Great, great.
Well that's all the questions
on my list for you today.
So do you guys have anything
you'd like to add before we go
and field questions from
the community?
SUI: Not really.
JOHN: I was going to ask--
you talked about how you were
going to enhance this app, do
you have any ideas for
a new app that you
guys are looking at?
SUI: A new app?
JOHN: Yeah, do you have any
crazy things you want to start
in maybe in more
than 24 hours.
SUI: Maybe not a Google hangout
application, but there
are a lot of a mobile
application I want to make.
Maybe a Google hangout
mobile application.
A mobile version of this.
JOHN: Good.
Cool idea.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, there's a
lot of good features there.
JENNY MURPHY: If we have
features like that, you'll be
the first to hear.
We'll let you know right away.
SUI: Yeah, I'm looking
forward to it.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
OK, so shall we switch over and
answer some questions from
the web developer community?
JOHN: So we, as always, we put
on our admins page the topic
for the speaker, a description
of the office hours, and then
he will present inline comments
and questions they
have. As usual we have a bunch
of feature requests, which we
are always happy to see and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] as feedback.
We would like to throw those
off to the feedback tool.
And as we mentioned, there's a
feedback tool in the lower
left hand side.
That's the best place to submit
feature requests around
the web experience--
each mobile app has
it's feedback
mechanism for that as well.
But for development questions,
we have a few.
JENNY MURPHY: Do you want ask
the media server one?
JOHN: So Joshua asked
about media servers.
So his question is, in the media
server app example, it
mentions only one media resource
can be active at a
time, image or audio.
Does this mean I use the hide
the image, overlay the play
the audio file and vice versa?
Does it mean I can have
one of each type?
So this is a good question.
Definitely for anybody who
hasn't looked at the media
stuff, it's really awesome and
interesting part of our API.
The way the plug-in works--
if you overlay an image, or if
you play a sound, that uses a
piece of memory.
And in the first release, memory
management it was good
but limited.
So we recommend only to do one
overlay at a time and not to
swap to many, because then
you're going to run into these
bad states memory.
The plug-in is being constantly
improved, so we've
got to get to a place where
you actually have multiple
overlays and swap
between them.
This would give you
animation effect.
You could try that today, but
it's probably going to work.
And different systems with
more or less memory will
behave differently.
In subsequent releases, we're
just improving the plug-in
better and better.
So you can now reliably
do that.
I haven't tested it lately,
but there will an upcoming
plug-in update that should
be able to support that.
The API won't change, so you
still do that with the API
today, just better memory
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So I'm going to ask a question
of you, Jonathan.
So it appears several
places in the
stream, people are asking--
how do I get hangouts on air?
JOHN: Yes, I actually
posted to our common
FAQs in that thread.
Right now, users are selected
by Google who can host
hangouts on air.
They reach out to us, we're
expanding this growing white
list and of course reach out and
we'll try to see if we can
accommodate you.
As we're building out the
infrastructure, as we're
building up the product, we're
slowly adding people to that
user base when it's ready
for mobile and general
availability.
The + pages are great places
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
JOHN: Ah--
JENNY MURPHY: Sure.
So I'll ask another one.
So [? Kosokay ?] asks, when can
we expect to have a menu
on the left with that lists all
the Google and we have 1.
Not referring to the profile tab
which lists external sites
we've +1, but instead the
content that's in Google .
To many of us here this is the
missing important feature.
There are favorite posts, it
would be incredibly useful to
have that list. Answer it.
So this is a great feature
request for the Google
application.
It's not something well
that's really key to
the platform itself.
So we really can can't
talk to it too much.
But, there's a great little
send feedback tool in the
bottom corner of-- depending
which language you're using--
bottom left or bottom right
corner of Plus.google.com.
So I strongly recommend you take
this feedback, hit that
button, and then describe
it in detail.
And all that feedback
gets read.
It all goes to a person, you
may not get a reply.
But some of it gets aggregated
and we listen to all of it.
JOHN: OK, apparently my volume
is a little bit low, so I'm
going to try to speak a little
bit louder, it wasn't a
problem last time.
Jean-Francois--
I'm not that much of
a [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Jean asks, geolocation for
hangout members displayed in
the hangout?
And that's a great idea.
Certainly it's something
that you
integrate into the hangout.
I'll take that as feedback
for the hangouts team.
But if you're interested in
coding, that sounds like a
cool little add-on.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So another question, which is
not in the comment stream, but
I've been hearing a little bit
lately is, what is with the
new profile badge?
So if you didn't notice,
yesterday we released a new
feature for the Google platform,
we released a new
social plug-in.
And it is a badge, just like the
badge that was previously
available for your Google pages,
except it works for
your profile.
And let me actually bring up
an example on the website.
You can see it in action.
So I've zoomed in here
quite a bit.
You can see that I've just taken
my personal hub page,
and I've just added
the Google badge.
And what it allows you to do is,
it allows visitors to your
website to easily add you
to one of their circles.
So if you have a hub page, or a
personal profile page that's
on a website, like your blog for
example, this is a great
feature you can put there.
Let me actually show you the
configuration tool for it.
So like everything else,
you can start at
developers.google.com/plus
and you can find it
on the plug-in section.
It's under badge--
and now badge has two different
configuration tools.
And there are two configuration
tools because
they're just a little
bit different.
When you go to this page, if
you're logged in to Google
developers, you're going to
see your badge right away.
It's going to pre-populate
your profile ID.
If it doesn't pre-populate,
you can hit a button that
would be over here to login.
And it will get at all set up.
Just like the other badge, the
configuration options allow
you to change the color--
so like for my darker layout.
You can also change the width
so it will fit in different
spots, so you can make it 100
pixels across, for example.
And the badge above
will change to
reflect those tweaks.
And then scrolling down,
you get the code
which is right here.
Which is just a few different
chunks of code which you paste
into your website, and
then the badge
will just start working.
So the first start is the
authorship link, which is just
how we figure out that link
between your profile page and
your webpage and validate
that link.
The next section is a big
chunk of JavaScript.
And this asynchronously
loads the JavaScript
that renders the badge.
Let me try to make it a little
bit bigger, it's
kind of small up there.
This asynchronously includes a
JavaScript that will render
the badge, and if you notice
it's identical to all the
other social plug-ins.
So if you're using a different
social plug-in like the 1
button, you don't need
to add this again.
And finally is the
badge itself.
So this code at the bottom--
zoom in a little more--
is the code for the
badge itself.
So you place this on your
page where you want
the badge to render.
And this is automatically
updated based on the changes
you made above.
So that's the new profile badge,
don't check it out.
And if you have any questions
you know where to find us.
JOHN: I just want to add
approach-- you mention that if
you're logged in it
automatically
adds your Google ID.
But if you are building a site
for somebody else or for a
friend, you can actually take
their Google ID off their
profile and create
a badge for them.
Right?
JENNY MURPHY: That's correct.
So if you go to somebody's
profile page--
let me zoom in quite a bit--
you can see their ID is this
number that's in the URL when
you're viewing their profile.
So if I'm viewing this person's
profile, who just
happens to be me in this silly
example, I can go over and
paste it into here.
I just pasted the same number
over it because it's me.
And then it will create a
badge for that person.
JOHN: We have a follow
up from Joshua--
when the app is hidden because
of clicking on the full video
feed or settings, et cetera,
then the app tab seems to
trigger the app to load again
including API ready.
Is this intended or do we detect
if the app has been
previously loaded, this
will not call
unique functions again.
So, I the answer to your
second question
is we have is visible--
I'd have to call back on
register whether or not the
app is being currently shown.
I'll have to reach out to you
directly to see what you mean.
Because that might just be a
bug because the developer
sandbox is this custom
environment.
Yeah, that sounds like to
a bug to me, and we
can look into it.
But for the visibility stuff,
yeah, there's a user callback
for is visible, I believe, the
right [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And then you can say whether or
not your app is being used
by the correct [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, hangouts
apps are still in developer
preview, so there occasionally
are little bumps
and bugs like that.
Thanks for pointing
it out to us.
We'll dig into it after
we finish recording.
Did you verify that you gave
him the correct call?
JOHN: It's different, a little
bit different, Because we
renamed the app, the
events in v0.2.
But is on app visible
dot ad or Google.
So if you go to
developers.googleplus.com
click on the hangouts link,
there's an API reference.
And that has all of our events,
I'm sure you are
looking at it, for anybody
who hasn't seen it.
In the hangouts name
space we have--
is the API ready?
Is the app visible?
Things like that.
So your app can be reacted
to states.
JENNY MURPHY: Great So we're
going to check the questions
feed one more time, but
we may be pretty much
done for this week.
Does anyone in the room have
anything they'd like to
discuss or ask questions
about at this time?
Great.
SUI: I just have a
question, sorry.
I just wondering to do we have
a way to publish application?
Is there like an app store or
a market or something for
Google hangout application?
JOHN: The platform itself is
still in developer preview.
During the developer preview,
the only way to add additional
users is directly to include
them into your team.
SUI: OK.
JOHN: In terms of distribution,
discovery, and all that.
That will be defined and
revealed once we
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
preview as something general.
Certainly the idea is
to not use as toys.
And to have people actually
use and enjoy your apps.
So more information on that will
be coming as available.
JENNY MURPHY: In other words,
we're working on it, hang
tight, it'll be awesome
when it's ready.
SUI: All right.
JENNY MURPHY: I promise
awesome.
JOHN: I +1 that.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
Well, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
MIN: I have one other
question--
I was having trouble getting
onto the hangout because it
kept freezing up when I
was trying to join.
What ended up solving was I
excited the Gmail and or the
Google+ page once I joined
the hangout.
Like right before you entered
the hangout, I excited all the
other application
and it worked.
Is that a bug on my part?
I think our other teammate is
having the same problem.
She couldn't join because
it was keep freezing.
JOHN: My first reaction is it
might be a bug in the plug-in.
Or a particular bug given
your environment
and operating system.
After this we'll just chat to
learn about your particular
set up and see if you have
an old plug-in version.
There's a couple of scenarios
where that might be the issue.
But yeah, the point of hangout
is to be part of hangout.
They classify that as a bug.
MIN: Right.
JENNY MURPHY: Well, I think
that unless anyone has
anything else they'd like to
chat about, I think that wraps
it up for this week.
So thanks all for bearing with
us, everyone out there.
It took us a couple more
minutes to get
started than usual.
And the video was
tiny, I know.
But check it out in the polished
version that we'll be
posting to
YouTube.com/googledevelopers.
All right, bye everybody.